Let me give you some advice bastard never forget what
you are.
Parents like armor, it can never be used ahead.
When I first heard they were interested in me for
a fantasy show.
I went no either the inkling reading the first boot
going Oh my God,
this is. This is amazing list could really kick off.
I was quite young and I had such a big
imagination in those scenes.
When I was younger. I would have really convinced myself
that I was there and it was happening,
you know they've never had any experience of acting before
I went to a very theatrically based drama school do
3 hours of camera training in 3 years,
but then my fourth hour in front of the camera
was day one on Game of Thrones.
My first turn step was causal.
Black my first scene was uh.
There's just a very quick scene where I'm walking down
the ramp arts and I was so nervous for my
birthday.
I'd set coming God, I fell off of.
This is my first job,
but this is like the first thing I ever did.
And they stuck in a horse I was falling off
the horse trying to act still.
OK, I fell again place and that was the king's
arrival.
The King writes in on horseback and he has to
get off his horse and his robe was enormous the
horse rides and he's like and then.
Hold everyone and then they run in with with making
like ladder.
They held him down and run out with the Latin
and carry on.
I vaguely remember it was like Sean Bean and Mark
Addy and Lena and I remember being so overwhelmed and
terrified.
I remember everybody clear remember baby Sophie and baby mezien
baby.
I zic and now they're out there full grown.
The most shocking scene that I didn't see coming.
From then on, I started to distrust the show as
to like whether they kill my favorite character or not.
I think the most shocking was probably my death,
the hotel moment I couldn't quite believe.
That was such as of Oh my God,
I watched the Red Wedding and I had didn't really
read into it.
Then the script of what happened.
I think I just did.
My Burton went lala and then when it came out.
I remember I watched it in the morning big guy
big tough guy,
but guess what? I burst into tears.
I was an absolute shocker remember just fortune going no
no no no no no no no Watts.
It was brilliant.
Do I have to call you lady start now?
Yes, my favorite day on set would be the day
that I was reunited with Maisie that day on sat
I've never laughed.
So much in my life.
It was so much fun the day with the wheels.
I've still got that video jeez mean so if we
just messing around on Brownsville.
I think the most fun scene.
We shot was season 7.
We shot this big sequence,
the loot train attack and we shot that in Spain.
It was such a beautiful.
And there's something about being outside everyday and being on
horseback.
I love riding go bag 80.
Season 3, getting the unsullied was the first time that
I Amelia got to be.
You know like Benton birders negate dinettes gel mass more
entered Gary or lantra.
Drake carries it was really cool.
Favorite day on set was definitely day in a suit
of when we were doing the gladitorial sequence my little
girl was there.
She watched the Papa work David said to you know
come sit here you can call and she was like
action.
The fights between the hound and Brienne of fucking tarth
would studied and trained for that.
Long time and going to all came to freshen that
was just fantastic.
Iceland season 2, the first day we were that that
was my favorite down on front.
I had never been to a more beautiful place in
my life and it was special for so many reasons.
It was the scene where I was.
Not able to Purdy grip.
Strike hard and true. Jon Snow.
My favorite actor to work with his rose.
Leslie there was something really special about working with rose
now.
I really, really enjoy working with John Bradley,
he saw this. Elevation.
A really enjoyed the scene with Mark Addy way back
in season one.
Just 'cause it was so it's hence.
No, I was like pages and pages long and it
was really unexpected from those 2 characters.
Sometimes I don't know what holds it together.
Call marriage.
Doesn't ease that I get with acting within Glen Cassis
pin my power the whole time there's been my one
my buddy in the most beautiful thing about Amelia.
She has no idea how good she is.
She genuinely's no idea and she still has no idea.
She's always of vulnerable which gives his part of her
part of a great gift.
I think in terms of my favorite scene partner.
They would have to be kit kit with the first
person I ever had,
and acting relationship with because it was my first job.
I think that the friendships that you for when you
are a bit scared and a bit uncertain and treading
unfamiliar ground there.
The ones that tend to stick because you cling onto
each other for support.
Santa come here little dove.
I always loved working with Lena?
What are you doing? Pray.
Perfect honey. Praying just watching her and learning from how
was the best drama lesson I could've ever hopeful?
I just paid my King your father now paying the
price.
I don't care. You my friend sure I'd accomplish things
were Terrien that I love down to have her level
of humanity.
On decency and cleverness and brightness.
He just treat her as an equal and I really
like that aspect not the relationship that they had.
I really miss Charles Dance,
who played my father Tywin Lannister.
We had such a great chemistry.
And a great friendship to noon RESP ITE are onscreen
relationship.
I'm very fortunate to work with the greatest cast everybody
is so professional and so incredibly.
Kind and generous to their fellow actors everyone involved is
like a family and it's a family.
That amazingly still laughs and gets on with each other
89 years in the dustbin not assholes.
North people depots. There's been normal.
Nothing not even a suggestion when it's all said and
done.
I'll miss the dynamic of the show 'cause.
There's nothing like this show or in Game of Thrones
means in my twenties.
I started this job when I was 22.
And I am not 22 anymore Game of Thrones is
my entire career.
I think I am going to have a hard time,
saying goodbye to Sam is going to be very hard
to say goodbye to paid theory and I will miss
simple things like walking on to set for the first
time each year in your new bits of costume and
just knowing you're part of something which is sort of
the center of attention.
Yes, can be very strange without has been 8 years.
I'll tell you why won't miss what Morrone with a
half of fucking beard.
Is the year?
Please turn brother. I was like a little puppy when
I arrived.
I was like Bambi. Uh on the ice and coming
to Belfast.
Just I learned how to walk.
With Pride and joy, I've grown up with these people.
I've changed so much as a person because of these
people.
I'm so confident I've just got this confidence from the
show and from playing Aria?
I really feel like I just want to inject that
into each and every person that I know and love.
But then also any girl that admires the work that
I do.
The journey that I've been on with Daenerys has sharpened
be as an actor.
It's shown me the range that I can do and
because of the.
Those 2 it's forced me to find them within myself
Game of Thrones has been such an education for me
and everything,
having to be around adults from the age of 10
and work on a professional set get up and learn
your lines and really think about character is also taught
me a lot about myself.
As an actor, you work,
and work and work and you auditioning you don't get
parts and you do get parts and sometimes they're great
experiences and sometimes they really shitty and this is being
incredible. Thrones is the Holy Grail where it's something that
is enormously globally massively popular and people think is cool
where people are always trying to copy things or do
variations of things to where you get something which is
completely original fantasy.
It's the most realistic show that I've ever done that
also happens to have.
Ends and dead people walking around in it,
I think a lot of fantasy is heavy on the
dragon in light on the character where the opposite.
This show will be discovered by generations to come.
It's timeless every season. There's something else bigger than the
last season and better than the last season and here
we are.
Season 8 it's cinematic were making 10 hour movies every
year.
The fact that this is really a full stop on
this story is sad because I think everyone's been so
invested in this story.
That we never want to see this come too close,
but it must and it will be good.